[Music]
students at home
keeping connected for halloween with a
virtual choir performance in what's cool
at school
[Music]
late one night when my eyes beheld an
eerie sight a halloween tradition
continues
we always would put together a halloween
performance
and even with 2020 being the year it's
been silvestri junior high school choir
still pulled off their halloween
performance
virtually i wanted to be able to give my
students an opportunity
to where even though they weren't
necessarily singing together in the
classroom
they still were able to experience that
choral
part of being a part of something the
month-long process involved crash
courses on adobe students filming two
separate videos with singing and
choreography
teachers pulling sound files from
sopranos altos
mixing them together to create monster
mash
it was a graveyard smash it was quite a
process to get that it made the hours
and hours of extra time just totally
worth it
for the choir family continuing their
halloween tradition during a pandemic
and the resulting distance learning
they've struggled through
was important maybe even necessary i
wanted them to
to feel like even though covet is going
on that we're still able to maintain
that sense of normalcy we can still
keep those traditions that are important
to to our school and to our choral
family
seems troubled by just one thing all 40
students that took part
lit up when they saw their performance
the best part of the project was
definitely watching their faces when i
showed them the final outcome
[Music]
when you get those videos and you're
watching them and you're like oh
they really are singing behind that
microphone or that bitmoji
figure or whatever it is that they have
on like there really is a kid there
and that's what's cool at school home
edition
if you know something that's cool at
school during these days of distance
learning
let us know about it send us an email
cool at school at 8newsnow.com